what we're going to do in this video is
start to think about how we describe
position in one dimension as a function
of time so we could say our position and
we're going to think about position on
the x-axis as a function of time and we
could define it by some expression let's
say in this situation it is going to be
our time to the third power minus three
times our time squared plus five and
this is going to apply for our time
being non-negative because the idea of
negative time at least for now is a bit
strange so let's think about what this
right over here is describing and to
help us do that we could set up a little
bit of a table
to understand that depending on what
time we are let's say that time is in
seconds what is going to be our position
along our x-axis
so time equals zero x of zero is just
going to be five
at time one you're gonna have one
minus three plus five
so that is going to be
see 1 minus 3 is negative 2
plus 5 is going to be we're going to be
at position 3. and then at time
we're going to be at 8
minus
12 plus 5 so we're going to be at
position
1 and then at time
t equals 3 is going to be 27 minus 27
plus 5. we're going to be back at 5. and
so this can at least help us understand
what's going on for the first three
seconds so let me draw
our positive x-axis
so
it looks something like
that
and
this is x equals zero this is our x-axis
x equals 1
and 5. and now let's let's play out how
this particle that's being described is
moving along the x-axis so we're going
to start here
and we're gonna go
one two
three let's do it again
we're going to go one two
three
the way i just moved my mouse if we
assume that i got the time roughly right
is how that particle would move and we
can graph this as well
so for example it could it would look
like this we are starting at time t
equals zero our position our what this
is our vertical axis our y-axis but
we're just saying y is going to be equal
to our position along the x-axis so
that's a little bit counter-intuitive
because we're talking about our position
our position in the left-right dimension
and here you're seeing it start off in
the vertical dimension but you see the
same thing at time t equals one our
position has gone down to three then it
goes down further at time equals two our
position is down to one and then we
switch direction and then over the next
if we say that time is in seconds over
the next second we get back to five
now an interesting thing to think about
in the context of calculus is well what
is our velocity at any point in time and
velocity as you might remember is the
derivative of position
so let me write that down so we're going
to be thinking about velocity as a
function of time and you could view
velocity as the first derivative of
position with respect to time which is
just going to be equal to we're going to
apply the power rule and some derivative
properties multiple times if this is unu
if this is unfamiliar to you i encourage
you to review it but this is going to be
3 t squared
minus 6 t
and then plus 0 and we're going to
restrict going to restrict the domain as
well for t is greater than or equal to
zero
and then we can plot that
it would look like that
now let's see if this curve makes
intuitive sense we mentioned that one
second two second three seconds
so we're starting moving to the left and
the convention is if you're moving to
the left you have negative velocity and
if you're moving to the right you have
positive velocity and you can see here
our velocity immediately gets more and
more negative until we get to one second
and then it stays negative but it's
getting less and less negative until we
get to two seconds and at two seconds
our velocity becomes positive and that
makes sense because at two seconds was
when our velocity switched directions to
the rightward direction so our velocity
is getting more and more negative less
and less negative and then we switch
directions and we go just like that and
we see it right over here now one thing
to keep in mind when we're thinking
about velocity as a function of time is
that velocity and speed are two
different things speed speed let me
write it over here speed is equal to if
you think about in one dimension you
could think about it as the absolute
value of your velocity as a function of
time or your magnitude of velocities as
a function of time so in the beginning
even though your velocity is becoming
more and more negative your speed is
actually increasing your speed is
increasing to the left then your speed
is decreasing you slow down and then
your speed is increasing as we go to the
right and we'll do some worked examples
that work through that a little bit more
now the last concept we will touch on in
this video is the idea of acceleration
an acceleration you could use the rate
of change of velocity with respect to
time
so acceleration as a function of time is
just going to be the first derivative of
velocity with respect to time which is
equal to the second derivative of
position with respect to time it's just
going to be the derivative of this
expression so once again using the power
rule here that's going to be 6t and then
using the power rule here minus
6 and once again we will restrict the
domain
and we can graph that as well
and we would see right over here this is
y is equal to acceleration as a function
of time and you can see at time equals
zero our acceleration is quite negative
it is negative six and then it becomes
less and less and less negative and then
our acceleration actually becomes
positive at t equals one now does that
make sense
well we're going one two three you might
say wait we didn't switch directions
until we get to the second second but
remember after we get to the first
second our our velocity our velocity in
the negative direction becomes less
negative which means that our
acceleration is positive if that's a
little confusing pause the video and
really think through that
so our acceleration is negative then
positive and then positive continues
and so this is just to give you an
intuition in the next few videos we'll
do several worked examples that help us
dive deeper into this idea of studying
motion and position
into this idea of studying motion in one
dimension